it seems like you are now the guy that
everyone goes to we rom-coms it's like
Noah and rom-coms are a thing no I do
not yet that be caught up Noah synteny
oh may be trading in those rom coms for
some time as a superhero what and I'm
just hoping we see a six-pack so it's
already been confirmed that Noah will be
reprising his role as Peter Kavinsky in
the - all the boys I've loved before
sequel hopefully we you know we explore
the darker sides of a relationship but
now Ichi has learned that the 22-year
old actor is in talks to play the lead
of he-man in the new Sony and Mattel
films flick Masters of the Universe
while the studio has no comment on the
report ET can confirm Mattel Films is in
active development with Sony Pictures on
the film the movie is said to be based
on the original he-man and the Masters
of the Universe story which launched the
super popular animated TV series in the
early 80s this year is actually turning
out to be super busy for the heartthrob
he also has a top-secret role in the
Charlie's Angels revival coming out
later this year really proud of him I
had a chance to sit down with Noah last
year on the heels of all that success
with Sierra Burgess as a loser and he
opened up about exploring a darker
character everyone right now is buzzing
over your rom-coms I want to know what
you ever want to play a villain have you
ever thought of something like that yeah
absolutely I'd love to turn around and
do something else I think there's a good
way to segue into different roles and
different genres not opposed to shaving
my head and like doing something Caillou
oh what a dreamboat he is so hot Cort
every single girl in this office was so
jealous of you that day
can you dish one behind the scenes
secret about Noah Noah is normal guys he
is so talented one but something that
might be surprising he's really flexible
and he smelled really good oh okay
marinate on that you guys of course as
more info comes out about the new key
man flick we'll be the first ones to
fill you in so be sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time guys I'm
Courtney teza know and I'm Hallie
Stevens
[Music]